[Applause]
21 grams that is the mass of all of the
electrons in your body if like me you
weigh about 70 kilograms now all of that
mass comes from the Higgs mechanism
which means that as your electrons are
traveling through space-time they
interact with the Higgs field and it's
that that gives them their mass it slows
them down and stops them from traveling
at the speed of light but most of your
mass doesn't come from the Higgs
mechanism and neither does all of the
stuff that you see around you the mass
is coming from somewhere quite different
and that's because most of your mass and
most of this mass comes from neutrons
and protons and they're not fundamental
particles they're made of Constituent
particles called quarks now the theory
that describes quarks and their
interactions with each other through
gluons is called quantum chromodynamics
and chromo is the Greek word for color
so in some way these objects are meant
to carry the color charge but they are
much much smaller than the wavelength of
visible light so there is no way that
they are actually colored but it's
useful analogy that helps us think about
how they interact and the particles that
they can make up now the rules are
pretty simple in order for a particle to
exist it must be colourless or white
like this house now you can accomplish
that in two different ways you could
make three quarks where each one is a
different color red green and blue so
overall they combine to produce white or
you could use a quark and an antiquark
where one is a color like green and the
other is it's anti color say magenta now
what I'd like to do on this little patch
of beach behind me is simulate how
quarks actually bind together and form
different particles now for this you
need to remember that in the last video
we talked about how empty space is not
truly empty so the beach here has these
undulations in it which represent the
fluctuations in the gluon field but you
have to imagine this beach sort of
rippling in these bumps coming and going
now that's really important because to
get rid of those fluctuations actually
takes energy and this is an important
part of binding the quarks together the
existence of quarks actually suppresses
the gluon fluctuations and creates
what's called a flux tube an area where
there is
really nothing in the vacuum and that's
in between this quark and the antiquark
and that pairs them up and creates
what's called a meson the quark
antiquark pair what's interesting about
the flux tube is that as these quarks
become more separated the flux tube
remains the same diameter and the same
sort of depth of suppression of the
field which means that the force doesn't
actually increase it's not like a spring
it's not like an elastic band the force
is the same that is pulling these quarks
back together but you are putting more
work in as you move these quarks and
antiquarks further apart and so for a
time people thought well these quarks
are always going to be confined however
far you move them it you're just going
to get a really long flux tube but what
actually happens is that you put in
enough energy that you can actually
create a quark antiquark pair now to
form a proton we're going to need an up
quark another up quark and a down quark
now the standard model of a proton that
you've probably seen involves these
quarks bounded together by little gluon
Springs that go between them the crazy
thing about a proton is that there may
be more than three quarks there you see
you can have additional quark anti quark
pairs pop in and out of existence so at
any given time there could be five or
seven or nine any odd number of quarks
could make up the proton so this is what
a proton actually looks like you can see
that the quarks like to sit on those
lumps in the gluon field and you can see
the two up quarks and a down quark but
there's also a strange quark and an anti
strange quark which is strange because
you don't normally think of these quarks
being inside a proton but they can be at
any particular point in time you can
also see that these quarks have cleared
out the vacuum and you can see there's
kind of these flux tubes which are the
areas where the gluon feel has been
suppressed
and that's really what's binding these
quarks together strong force that binds
quarks it is intrinsically related to
the fact that clearing out those
fluctuations has more energy than where
they are that's right so where is the
mass the proton really coming from well
of course the Constituent quarks do
interact with the Higgs field and that
gives them a small amount of mass but if
you add up the mass of all the quirks in
the proton it would only account for
about one percent of its total mass so
where's the rest of the mass coming from
the answer is energy you know Einstein's
famous equation e equals MC squared well
that says we've got a lot of energy for
just a little bit of mass but if you
rearrange the equation you can see that
we can get an amount of mass if there is
lots of energy there and that is really
where most of the mass the proton is
coming from
it's from the fact that there are these
energy fluctuations in the gluon field
and the quarks are interacting with
those gluons that is where your mass is
coming from it's coming from the energy
that's in there you know Einstein talked
about well if I had a hot cup of tea it
would actually have a slightly greater
mass than the same cup of tea when cold
and he was right I mean you can't
measure it with a cup of tea but most of
your mass you owe to e equals mc-squared
you owe to the fact that your mass is
packed with energy because of the
interactions between the quarks and
these gluon fluctuations in that gluon
field I think it's extraordinary because
what we think of is ordinarily empty
space you know that turns out to be the
thing that gives us all most of our mass
I really want to thank audible.com for
supporting this episode of veritasium in
case you don't know audible.com is a
leading provider of audiobooks with over
a hundred thousand titles in all areas
of literature including fiction
nonfiction and periodicals you know one
of my favorite books is by James Gleick
it's called the information a history a
theory of flood and if you head on over
to audible.com slash veritasium you can
download it right now for free
or you can pick another book of your
choosing
you know it's great to have support from
people like audible because that allows
me to keep making this content for you
for free so please go check it out